Bộ Quốc trong tim bản xong hưởng của lòng yêu nước sẽ chính thức dễ dạ vào 20 giờ ngày buổi tháng tạm tại xân bản động Quốc xà miên đình.
Đây là sự kiện và nhoa chính trị đặc biệt trong 1 tạm 15 kích bản tháng tạm và Quốc khánh hai tháng chiến.
Sơn khấu được tiếp kế hình chứ về cao 20 sau mết, mang ít của nguyên biệt khuận niềm tin, khát bọng và lòng từ hào xân tộc.
Không gián được chia làm muốn buộc biểu thượng, độc lập từ gió hạnh phúc và cơ đó sau vạng.
Những ca khúc parh của nguyên linh đàn đường lên phí trước được làm mới bằng cảm quan đường đại.
Nánh thức nghiệm từ hào thương liên quà mũi dài điều.
Mỗi mỗi mọi phần xong có một đối tượng hả hả giường thì tổ phu trông kiên là ử ra đi chè.
Ông ở là tháng tân, người à thúng gà, đối tụi tụi tụi.
Đó không làm một số đức.
Pởi khách hàng chung ngăn khăn ra đứng dậy, cùng nhau hết Quốc ca, dì là cơ đó sau phản tung bay sẽ là điểm trạm xúc cảm không thể quyền.
Mỗi người không chỉ là khán ra mà chính là một nghiệp là trong trạm kiếm tổ Quốc.